hi it's michelle from lab muffin beauty
science chemistry phd and skincare nerd
today we're talking about alcohol
not drinking alcohol alcohol in skincare
i knew that
alcohol is one of the most controversial
ingredients in skincare
you'll hear things like alcohol can dry
out your skin give you premature
wrinkles
and kill your skin cells but is this
really true
i've been looking at what the research
says about this topic with stephen
hi everyone i'm stephen from kind of
steven i'm
a cosmetic formulator and a friend of
michelle's and you can find me on
instagram
at kind of stephen today we're going to
be talking about the alcohols in
skincare
why they're there and whether they're
worth avoiding in particular we're going
to be talking about ethyl alcohol or
ethanol or denatured alcohol
since this is the main controversial
alcohol if you like this sort of video
please give it a thumbs up subscribe to
my channel
and click the notification bell let's
start by looking at exactly what alcohol
is
in chemistry an alcohol is any
carbon-based compound that contains an
oxygen bonded to a hydrogen
an oh or hydroxyl group so for example
all of these chemicals are alcohols but
just because they're alcohols doesn't
mean that they have the same properties
on your skin
for example glycerin and glycols are
humectant moisturizers that will hydrate
your skin
sucrose is table sugar settle alcohol is
a fatty alcohol which doesn't evaporate
much at all and it feels oily on your
skin
for some people it's beneficial as a
moisturizer in other people it breaks
them out
so yes some alcohols can be beneficial
for your skin but when people talk about
alcohols in skin care
usually they're referring to the more
volatile alcohols which are the ones
that evaporate quickly off your skin
these have a reputation for being drying
and irritating
and in particular what they mean is
usually ethanol
or ethyl alcohol so what is ethanol
ethanol ethyl alcohol or denatured
alcohol is mostly the same alcohol that
you find in alcoholic drinks
so i think there's some confusion about
what denatured alcohol is
i've read online that it's harsher for
your skin that it's more gentle
that it's another molecule altogether
and that's not the case
so it's still in this case ethanol the
same molecule
except there's been different
ingredients that have been added in to
discourage people from drinking it
why is alcohol in skin care products
ethanol is included in skin care
products for a few different reasons
stephen is a cosmetic formulator who has
lots of experience in using different
ingredients in skin care products
so he is going to take us through some
of these roles so ethanol
is a really useful solvent it can
dissolve things that normally can
dissolve in water but it can also
dissolve
things that normally don't dissolve in
water so a lot of fragrances for example
will come in
a ethanol or alcohol base and that's
because the fragrance oils and perfumes
that don't normally dissolve in water
are able to dissolve in alcohol
salicylic acid for example is an
anti-acne ingredient so it has a very
low solubility in water but
actually dissolves quite readily in
ethanol so a lot of older formulations
with salicylic acid you'll usually see
an ethanol component so ethanol can also
be used as
a solvent to extract ingredients from
plant material for example like vanilla
extract it can also be used to
remove lipids oils and waxes from the
skin
if you look at older toner formulations
and
makeup removers a lot of them also had
ethanol in them to help remove
makeup soil and dirt this is a lot less
common now
but a high concentration of ethanol can
also be used as a preservative in a
cosmetic formula so another property of
ethanol is that it's very volatile which
means that it's very fast evaporating
so that gives it a very quick spreading
texture and also like a very quick
drying
cooling effect on the skin that's often
used in sunscreens to make their texture
lighter and help them evaporate and set
faster ethanol can also be used as a
skin penetration enhancer for certain
ingredients and that means it'll help
get those ingredients deeper into the
skin at a higher concentration than
without it
so a lot of formulas are now replacing
ethanol with
glycols like propane diol or propylene
glycol propane dial and propylene glycol
both
have alcohol functional groups on them
that oh group but they don't have the
volatility
the fast evaporation that ethanol does
so they actually remain on the skin
and they can give like that glowy
glistening effect on the skin
so that's good for some formulations but
not necessarily all formulations
i chatted to susan of mix makeup about
some products she uses that have alcohol
in them and what it's doing in there
i've put the link to her video in the
description so
alcohol is pretty useful for beauty
products but doesn't have a dark side
so i generally try to avoid making
formulations with ethanol if it can be
avoided
that's not necessarily because i think
it's dangerous or harmful just that i
know
that people in the beauty community
really aren't looking for formulations
with ethanol anymore
there are lots of in vitro studies where
the effects of alcohol on cells in a
dish were studied
and the results of these are pretty
scary alcohol can make cells die in a
process called apoptosis
it can make cells produce inflammatory
signals it can denature proteins
and it can stop enzymes from working and
we know that alcohol is a really good
disinfectant
it can kill bacteria very quickly but
skin is very different from naked cells
in a dish
or a single bacterium made up of just
one cell we have about 10 to 20 layers
of dead skin cells on the surface of our
skin
the stratum corneum before we get to the
living layers of cells
and these dead cells aren't just any
dead cells they're toughened with
keratin
and they're sitting in an oily goop
which is really really good at
preventing things from entering and
leaving
so for ethanol to affect our living skin
cells like it does in the in vitro
studies
it would firstly have to get through
this extremely efficient barrier
in a high enough concentration to make a
difference while most of these in vitro
studies used relatively
low concentrations of ethanol somewhere
around 0.5 percent
they also left the cells in contact with
the ethanol for a really long time
sometimes 24 hours in a container where
the alcohol couldn't evaporate
but ethanol when we apply it to our skin
is very volatile
it evaporates very easily and you'll
have felt this when you feel the cool
sensation from an alcohol containing
product
this is the alcohol evaporating and
taking some of your body heat with it it
turns out that when you apply ethanol on
your skin
the vast majority of it will evaporate
so one experiment used pig skin to take
a look at how quickly 100
ethanol evaporated off the skin and what
they found was that after 10 seconds
more than 50 of it had already
evaporated overall they found that
about three percent less than three
percent was left on the skin
now there's some issues with that three
percent uh because they think that some
of the alcohol had actually leaked under
the chamber
of their test equipment so it's actually
likely that it's much much less
so what we can infer from this is that
if you're using a skincare product with
ethanol in the formula
maybe around five to ten percent then
more than 97 of that is going to
evaporate off the skin
very quickly so all of these studies
showing that alcohol was bad for cells
in a dish
we can't immediately apply them to the
way that we use alcohol in skin care the
most relevant studies for us would be
the ones where they looked at alcohol
being applied to human skin
and observing what happened as i've
mentioned before it's often really hard
to find good skin care studies because
most scientific research is funded by
the government so there needs to be a
really good public health reason for
doing the research
otherwise it might be funded by a beauty
brand or an ingredient company
in which case there needs to be a strong
commercial reason for doing the study
luckily there is a relevant situation
where people do end up applying lots and
lots of alcohol to their skin
in much larger quantities and much more
often than we would in skincare that's
in healthcare where alcohol-based hand
sanitizers are used by healthcare
workers to prevent spreading of diseases
in particular nurses have to disinfect
their hands between patients
and this adds up one study found that on
average
nurses had to clean their hands 55 times
a day lots of nurses end up with crack
skin irritation and blisters on their
hands from this repeated cleaning
it's been found that skin irritation
makes people less likely to follow hand
hygiene procedures
and so there's a really compelling
public health reason to research this
the main methods for disinfecting hands
are washing your hands with soap and
water
and alcohol-based hand rubs so there's
been quite a few clinical studies
comparing soap and water versus alcohol
hand rubs
and between different hand rub formulas
on things like skin irritation
dryness cracking and so on so what do
these studies tell us
what a lot of these studies are showing
us is that even using
a very large amount of ethanol in the
skin doesn't really have a huge
long-term impact let's look at one of
the more recent detailed studies on
alcohol-based hand rubs to get an idea
of how these studies are conducted this
article which i've linked in the
description was published in 2017
in the international journal of cosmetic
science it's open access so you can
download it and read it as well the
clinical part of this study involved
testing three different alcohols at 70
concentration
on the inner forearms of 25 white female
volunteers
aged 35 to 50. a fourth area of skin had
water applied as a comparison the
solutions were rubbed into skin for
about 10 seconds
either 20 times a day or 100 times a day
the skin was also washed six times a day
with hand wash and water to mimic what
would happen for a typical nurse
this process was done for 14 days around
every two days the scientists measured
skin hydration
redness and trans epidermal water loss
this is how much water was evaporating
through the skin a way of measuring skin
barrier function
so these hand wrap studies usually use
alcohol concentrations far higher than
we would see in skincare plus they used
it many more times a day plus there's
that extra irritation from the repeated
cleansing as well it's likely that
whatever effects these studies find will
be a bigger version of what would happen
to us
when we apply a moisturizer or sunscreen
with 5 or 10 ethanol in them
so what were the findings of these
studies one of the biggest questions is
does alcohol cause
inflammation inflammation isn't good for
skin it's been linked to lots of skin
issues like acne rosacea and premature
aging
and in some in vitro cell studies
alcohol does seem to be able to cause
cells to release inflammatory markers
but will this happen on actual skin in
these hand rub studies
inflammation was measured by looking at
skin redness inflammation causes blood
flow to increase
and so you get a reddening effect and in
several of these studies
scientists found that ethanol didn't
seem to be linked to skin redness
compared to no ethanol this was even the
case in a study where 70 ethanol was
applied to the skin
a hundred times a day for 14 days there
was no statistically significant
difference in redness compared to water
applied 100 times a day
so that is a total of 1400 applications
of ethanol over two weeks
another question about alcohol is
whether or not it can disrupt your skin
barrier to a harmful extent
your skin's main job is to act as a
barrier between you
and the outside world the top dead
layers of skin the stratum corneum
are essential to this function to act as
an effective barrier this stratum
corneum has to keep itself maintained
the dead skin cells have to continuously
shed
smoothly and the oily lipids in between
the cells have to stay in an organized
formation
on isolated skin samples in vitro
enzymes that are important in cell
shedding and in the production of oily
lipids can be disturbed
and so they don't work as well there are
also some in vitro studies that suggest
that alcohol
can temporarily modify how molecules are
arranged in your skin or it can remove
lipids from your skin
in a process called lipid extraction
this isn't like it's making your skin
fall apart or anything
it's much more subtle microscopic
changes for example
how the oily molecules are arranged
relative to each other
and this effect doesn't last for long
it's thought that this is how
ethanol helps ingredients penetrate your
skin but these findings aren't really
consistent
many times skin samples even if they
were left with alcohol for a really long
time
there weren't big negative effects and
many of these studies do actually point
out that the conditions that they use
don't reflect how we would use
alcohol on our skin in the clinical
studies ethanol doesn't really seem to
disrupt the barrier much
skin barrier disruption is usually
measured through trans-epidermal water
loss this is how much water is escaping
through skin
into the air and so a more disruptive
barrier would cause
greater water loss in multiple hand rub
studies changes in trans-epidermal water
loss were minor
even with 20 applications of alcohol a
day there was a measurable difference in
one study but that was when ethanol was
applied a hundred times a day
much more than we would in skincare
unless you have a very strange skincare
routine
one thing that can seem to happen with
alcohol is dehydration there have been
mixed results in clinical studies
some have found that alcohol does
decrease hydration while others haven't
for example in the kartner study that i
mentioned earlier skin hydration wasn't
significantly different between ethanol
and water whether you applied it 20
times a day or 100 times a day
in another study skin oil content didn't
change significantly
after applying hand rails containing 60
to 80
alcohol 50 times a day for a week
however there are ways to help with
dehydration and dryness
one study looked at adding moisturizing
ingredients like glycerin and lanolin
and fatty alcohols to hand rubs this
study used hand rubs containing propanol
which has been found in other studies to
be more irritating than ethanol they
found that these moisturizing
ingredients decreased the amount of
redness and dryness that the propanol
caused
in skin care propanol is really rare and
we almost always find ethanol combined
with these moisturizing ingredients
what about stinging one reason that we
tend to be a bit scared of alcohol is
that you sometimes get that painful
stinging sensation
but multiple studies have found that
that stinging painful sensation
doesn't actually mean that harm is being
done to your skin
alcohol does tend to sting your skin if
it's already damaged
the alcohol can go through the skin and
touch the nerve endings
which caused the pain this is like a
more sensitive version of what happens
when water gets into a paper cut
so what does this mean for alcohol in
skin care these studies on alcohol hand
rubs aren't done under the same
conditions as we would use
alcohol in skincare but they're a lot
closer than in vitro studies the studies
were mostly on
arm skin which is thicker and less
sensitive than face skin plus these
studies only lasted a week or two but
they use
far far higher concentrations of alcohol
and many many more times than we would
use
alcohol in a skincare routine some of
these studies also introduce
extra irritation from cleansing many
more times than we would in a skincare
routine
there's also the fact that in skin care
products we have other ingredients like
glycerin which will reduce the impact of
alcohol
in terms of dryness or redness or
irritation so overall the evidence seems
to point towards alcohol not being a big
deal in skincare
given how small the impact was under the
much more extreme conditions in these
hand rub studies
i hope you enjoyed this video if you did
click the thumbs up subscribe to my
channel and click the notification bell
and if you have any of the topics that
you would like us to cover
leave a comment below with your
suggestion you can also follow us on
instagram and check out our blogs
and drop a like if you like this video
and subscribe
if you loved it thanks stay sciency